und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend in St Petersburg hat
heute die größte marineparade Russlands
stattgefunden wie immer am letzten
Sonntag im Juli und für Putin scheint
auch alles wie immer zu sein denn seinen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine erwähnte
der russische Präsident nicht mit einem
einzigen Wort als würde es Ihnen einfach
gar nicht geben aber es gibt ihn seit
nunmehr 522 Tagen heute gab es Meldungen
über Drohnen Angriffe und zwar auf
beiden Seiten einen Überblick verschafft
uns jetzt da er Anton
ein Riesenloch klafft dort wo einst ihr
Klassenzimmer war somi im Nordosten der
Ukraine die Raketen treffen die
Berufsschule in der Nacht mit voller
Wucht treffen auch Schlafsäle zwei
Menschen sterben nach ukrainischen
Angaben 20 werden verletzt
im Süden der Ukraine bei einem weiteren
russischen Angriff hier sterben ein Mann
und eine Frau die Druckwelle der
Detonation ist so enorm dass die Fenster
von benachbarten Geschäften und
Hochhäusern zerbersten olina sitzt in
ihrem parkhäuschen die Frontscheibe
ihres Schalters zerstört
es passierte ganz plötzlich die
Granatsplitter schlugen ins Glas alles
sprang raus das ganze glasflug hier hin
sind sie okay mir geht es gut Gott sei
Dank
Russland meldet Drohnenangriffe
Aufräumarbeiten an der Fassade eines
Wolkenkratzers mitten in mosquacity wo
auch mehrere russische Ministerien ihren
Sitz haben diese filmeaufnahme soll den
Einschlag einer Drohne zeigen
insgesamt Treffen nach russischen
Angaben zwei Drohnen einen Bürokomplex
eine weitere sei am Stadtrand
abgeschossen worden Oskars Bürgermeister
meldet einen verletzten Wachmann
russland sieht die Ukraine hinter den
Angriffen spricht von einem versuchten
Terrorangriff am Abend meldet sich
ukraines Präsident selenski zu Wort
die Ukraine wird stärker allmählichkeit
der Krieg auf das Territorium Russlands
zurück in seine symbolischen Zentren um
Militärstützpunkte dass die Drohnen aus
der Ukraine über hunderte Kilometer
hinweg ungehindert Richtung Moskau
geflogen sind halten die wenigsten für
wahrscheinlich ein Sabotageakt sei
denkbar ein neuer Drohnenangriff in der
Hauptstadt ein Problem für die Führung
in Moskau
durch den Angriffskrieg Russlands wurden
Deutschlands eher zögerliche Pläne für
einen Umbau in Sachen Energieversorgung
mit einer Art Turbo versehen die Klima
schädlichen CO2-Emissionen zu reduzieren
das rückte kurz in den Hintergrund denn
zunächst ging es ja darum sich aus der
russischen gasabhängigkeit zu lösen und
das ist in weiten Teilen gelungen auch
mit strittigen Deals Stichwort
Flüssiggas aus Katha die
Herausforderungen bei der Energiewende
die bleiben ja aber bestehen Stichworte
sind da der Ausbau an sich der aus- und
Umbau der Netzinfrastruktur Kosten und
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz wie man das
mit der Akzeptanz schaffen kann das
zeigen Andreas Weise und Hagen Mikulas
am Beispiel südostling in Sachsen-Anhalt
ein sachsen-anhaltischer Exportschlager
Strom aus Sonne und Wind über 60% des
hier erzeugten Stroms liefern
erneuerbare Quellen auch deshalb
entsteht in Wolmirstedt bei Magdeburg
eine Trafostation als Ausgangspunkt für
eine gut 500 Kilometer lange stark
Stromtrasse bis zum ehemaligen
wir planen bis Mitte 2025 die
Bauarbeiten abzuschließen und dann noch
in 25 in Betrieb zu gehen der trafo-bau
ist aber auch alles was bislang von der
Stromtrasse Südost Link zu sehen ist
noch kein Kabel gelegt kein Meter
Leitung gespannt dabei sollte die
gesamte stromautobahn zwischen
Sachsen-Anhalt und Bayern ursprünglich
bis 2025 ans Netz gehen jetzt soll es
2027 soweit sein
bereits vor 10 Jahren von der damaligen
schwarz-gelben Bundesregierung
beschlossen sollten Stromtrassen
günstigen Windstrom zu den industriellen
Zentren im Süden und Südwesten leiten
doch Proteste gegen die neuen überland
Kabel befeuert durch den damaligen
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten Seehofer
durch kreuzen die Pläne erstmal
solange die Notwendigkeit nicht belegt
ist
wird ein neues Seehofer auf einer
Stromleitung nicht zustimmen 2015 dann
ein neuer Kabinettsbeschluss Erdkabel
statt Freileitungen für mehr Akzeptanz
für die Energiewende den Zeitplan war
das um Jahre zurück
wenn man die Planungsgrundlage von wir
bauen über der Erde auf wir bauen unter
der Erde ändert dann sind plötzlich
andere Grundstückseigentümer betroffen
dann sind archäologische Fragen an das
zu behandeln und das hat eben dann die
Verfahren noch mal neu aufrollen lassen
und das hat Zeit gekostet und teure wird
es auch statt ursprünglich rund 10
Milliarden Euro soll alles nun ca 30
Milliarden kosten seit 2013 gibt es die
Planungen für drei große Stromtrassen
von Nord nach Süd mit 3117 km
Gesamtlänge stand heute sind davon
gerade 46 km genehmigt beziehungsweise
vollendet und überhaupt so manche
Kritiker sei es viel besser mehr auf die
regionale Energiewende zu setzen
die stromtrassenplanung insgesamt ist
sehr stark auf die
Stromnetzbetreiber Bedürfnisse
ausgerichtet die Energiewende ist aber
dezentral sie ist nicht zentral das
heißt wir werden nicht nur Großprojekte
haben sondern viele kleine und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir vor allen Dingen
im Süden Deutschlands mehr erneuerbare
Energien ausbauen vor allem bei der
Windkraft haben Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg danach Expertenmeinung
nach Nachholbedarf
und ich freue mich sehr dass ich
Veronika Grimm heute für uns Zeit nimmt
die Professorin ist in zahlreichen
Gremien und Beiräten aktiv unter anderem
im nationalen wasserstoffrat der
Bundesregierung und auch im Rat für
Verbraucherfragen des Umweltministeriums
zudem ist sie seit drei Jahren Mitglied
des Sachverständigenrats und mit ihr
möchte ich gar nicht so sehr über
einzelne Maßnahmen sprechen sondern eher
über das grundsätzliche wo stehen wir wo
haarparts was braucht es und damit einen
schönen guten Abend Frau Professorin
guten Abend Frau Janni es ist ja so dass
manche glauben dass das mit der
Energiewende nicht gelingen wird manchen
geht es zu schnell manchen zu langsam
erleben Sie die Energiewende mit der
Brechstange
der zunächst mal ist es so dass wir sehr
konsequent ausgestiegen sind aus der
Kohle wollen wir aussteigen bis 20 30
aus der Atomkraft sind wir jetzt mitten
in der Gaskrise ausgestiegen und wir
sind zwangsweise aus dem russischen Gas
ausgestiegen das heißt es muss jetzt
auch sehr viel sehr schnell passieren um
das zu kompensieren um also einzusteigen
in die erneuerbaren Energien und die
Leitungen auszubauen Flexibilisierung
der Strom Nachfrage zu schaffen damit
wir eben nicht so viel Leitungsausbau
brauchen und das erfordert alles viel
politischen Willen jetzt haben sie schon
ein paar Punkte genannt was braucht es
denn noch
ja wir haben einerseits die
Herausforderung bei den Erneuerbaren wir
müssen jetzt ganz viel ganz schnell ganz
viel erneuerbare ausbauen aber um die
Erneuerbaren abzufedern die Erneuerbaren
sind ja fluktuierend produzieren dann
wenn die Sonne scheint oder der Wind
weht brauchen wir auch Gaskraftwerke
mehr Gaskraftwerke um die
Kohlekraftwerke zu kompensieren die wir
ja abschalten wollen bis möglichst 2030
wie es im Koalitionsvertrag steht und
diese Kohlekraft diese Gaskraftwerke
sollen wasserstofftauglich sein das
heißt wir wollen sie dann spätestens
2035 mit Wasserstoff betreiben und das
bedeutet dass wir viel Wasserstoff
beschaffen oder produzieren müssen und
da braucht es auch wieder die
Produktionskapazitäten und die
leitungsinfrastrukturen und vor allen
Dingen dann keine neue Abhängigkeiten
möglicherweise von beziehungsweise mit
arabischen Ländern lassen Sie uns mal
auf die Akzeptanz schauen im
Grundsätzlichen da sind ja viele Bürger
und Bürgerinnen dabei aber wenn es dann
konkret wird eher nicht also niemand
Willen Windrad in seinem Garten stehen
haben jetzt mal ein bisschen zugespitzt
und hinzu kommen dann noch
Überforderungen bzw Ablehnung gewisser
Maßnahmen sie sagten deshalb kürzlich
die Polarisierung nehme jetzt schon
bedenkliche Ausmaße an die großen
Zumutungen die kommen erst noch also was
ist denn jetzt zu tun mehr erklären
weniger streiten
ich glaube zunächst ist es mal wichtig
dass wir jetzt sehen dass wirklich viel
geschehen muss es droht ja nicht das
Windrad im Garten sondern es muss die
Windenergie ausgebaut werden und das
sehr schnell und es muss
Leitungskapazität geschaffen werden und
natürlich wird das den ein oder anderen
Bürger betreffen und natürlich müssen
wir auch schneller sein mit dem
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren und
das setzt auch voraus dass man mit den
akzeptanzfragen auch schneller in
weniger Instanzen idealerweise umgeht
auf der anderen Seite brauchen wir
natürlich auch viel Kapazität weil wir
ja die Strompreise wieder runter
bekommen wollen es ist ja so dass
aktuell die Strompreise sehr hoch waren
jetzt sind sie wieder ein bisschen
gesunken aber das strompreisniveau ist
noch nicht ideal also der Ausbau von
Kapazitäten ist auch dafür wichtig die
Strompreise tatsächlich wieder runter zu
bekommen auf in der mittleren Frist und
da muss man natürlich auch die Bürger
jetzt mitnehmen
und ich glaube den meisten ist vor allen
Dingen auch in den letzten Monaten klar
geworden spätestens in den letzten
Monaten dass der Klimaschutz natürlich
den gibt es dann nicht zum Nulltarif die
Energiewende ist klar darüber haben wir
gerade gesprochen muss im Einklang mit
den Bürgern aber vor allen Dingen ja
auch im Einklang mit der Wirtschaft
passieren und da sagte jetzt der
bayerische Wirtschaftsminister Aiwanger
wir haben zu hohe Energiepreise zu hohe
Steuern wir sind nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig was sagen sie als
Wirtschaftsweise dazu
ja die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit müssen wir
herstellen indem wir möglichst schnell
möglichst viel Energieangebot ausbauen
dann gehen auch die Strompreise runter
wir dürfen das auch nicht zu sehr mit
der Brechstange machen natürlich wir
haben das ja beim heizungsgesetz auch
gesehen wenn man zu stark mit
Ordnungsrecht arbeitet dann trifft man
eben einige sehr hart und muss dann
wieder sozusagen die Härte das Gesetzes
zurücknehmen dann greift es aber nicht
mehr in dem Umfang wie man sich das
vorstellt insofern ist jetzt schon
angesagt sehr viel umfangreicher auch
mit der CO2 Bepreisung zu arbeiten und
mit der CO2 Bepreisung würde man ja Geld
einnehmen sozusagen dass man dann auch
wieder zurückgeben kann um Härten
abzufedern das wäre jetzt das Mittel der
Wahl ich glaube wenn man jetzt künstlich
die Strompreise reduziert für einzelne
z.B wie vorgeschlagen durch einen
Industriestrom weiß dann ist nicht so
viel geholfen weil man dann einzig
einzelnen hilft aber andere dafür im
Gegenzug dann höre Strompreise erfahren
werden entweder weil sie diese
Subvention bezahlen müssen indirekt über
Aufschläge auf den Strompreis oder auch
weil durch die Subventionen der
Energieverbrauch der energieintensiven
Industrie zunehmen wird und dann
natürlich wieder bei knappenangebot auch
der Preis am Strommarkt steigen wird
also das ist nicht glücklich man muss
jetzt schauen dass man schnell mit dem
Ausbau vorankommt und auch nicht zu viel
rum diskutiert immer wieder ob man jetzt
bestimmte Maßnahmen braucht oder nicht
braucht ich glaube wir brauchen ganz
viele Maßnahmen ganz dringend ganz
schnell und da muss jetzt die Planung
und Genehmigung auch schneller
vorangehen ehepunktes angekommen und die
CO2-Zertifikate das ist noch mal ein
eigenes Thema da gibt's viele Pros aber
auch Kontrast V Professorin vielen
herzlichen Dank für das Interview und
auch für ihre Zeit heute
ich danke ihnen schönen Abend
mit 9 Euro ist es damals gestartet jetzt
kostet es 49 Euro wie erfolgreich das
deutschlandticket ist damit beginnen
deine Nachrichten Gundula eine gemischte
Bilanz des deutschlandtickets ziehen
nach drei Monaten Bahn und der
Fahrgastverband pro Bahn er kritisiert
man habe nicht wirklich Menschen in
großen Mengen in den öpnv-locken können
obwohl die Nutzung billiger und
einfacher geworden sei die Deutsche Bahn
spricht dagegen von einem großen Erfolg
im Juni habe sie im regional und
Nahverkehr 25% mehr Fahrgäste gezählt
als vor der Einführung des 49 € Tickets
im Mai in der Nordsee haben
Bergungsteams damit begonnen den
brennenden Auto Frachter abzuschleppen
vor der niederländischen Küste wird das
Schiff langsam und kontrolliert von zwei
Schleppern zu einem vorläufigen
Ankerplatz vor der Wattenmeerinsel
Schiermonnikoog gebracht starke Winde
aus der falschen Richtung hatten das
zuvor verhindert sie hätten die Boote
der Bergungsteams in raucht der Brand
auf dem Frachter ist zwar schwächer
geworden aber die Gefahr des Kern des
Kenterns ist noch nicht gebannt
nach dem Putsch im Niger hat die
westafrikanische Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
Ecowas alle Handels- und
Finanzbeziehungen zu dem Land ausgesetzt
und mit dem Einsatz von Gewalt gedroht
tausende Anhänger der kutschisten
protestierten in der Hauptstadt niami
gegen eine mögliche Intervention andere
afrikanischer Staaten einige
Demonstranten griffen zudem die
französische Botschaft an und forderten
eine Annäherung an Russland
kurze aber intensive Unwetter haben
gestern Abend in Südtirol teils schwere
Schäden verursacht unterhalb des
grödnerjochs in den Dolomiten
verschüttete eine geröllawine mehrere
Fahrzeuge auf einem Parkplatz verletzt
wurde niemand genauso wie im Osten der
italienischen Provinz im Pustertal
rissen Wassermassen Holzbrücke mit sich
welche entwickelten sich innerhalb
kürzester Zeit zu reißenden Strömen
wir blicken jetzt in Ausschnitten auf
das heutige zdf-sommer-interview bei dem
der
co-parteivorsitzende der Linken Martin
schedewand zu Gast war und Themen gibt
es da ja genug Sahra Wagenknecht die
laut Umfragen auf Anhieb mehr Wähler
hinter sich versammeln würde als ihre
man weiß es ja nicht ganz genau noch
Partei was allerdings wenn man es
zynisch formulieren möchte auch keine
große Kunst ist denn die Linke liegt bei
gerade einmal vier Prozent bundesweit
damit droht der Linken die
Bedeutungslosigkeit da kann man schon
auch nachvollziehen dass bei
Parteiveranstaltungen zwischendurch die
Nerven blank liegen Daniel pontzen
entschuldige bitte es gibt derzeit
Herausforderungen bei der Linken die
sind vergleichsweise leicht zu lösen
Thomas kannst du mal bitte kurz kommen
andere weniger kürzlich diskutierten
Mitglieder über die Zukunft der Partei
unter der Fragestellung ob die Linke
noch zu retten sei dabei kam es dann
auch zu diesem sehr energischen
Wortbeitrag zu NATO
[Musik]
natürlich ist NATO ein Kriegsbündnis
ohne Wenn und Arbeit hat niemand eine
andere Position überhaupt niemand andere
Position die Frage war jetzt eine ganz
schlichte ob wir dieses soziale Thema
zum zentralen Thema machen das soziale
zum zentralen Thema machen dies ist die
schwierige die ungelöste Herausforderung
der Partei wofür genau steht die Linke
was muss sie tun gerade im Osten gerade
im Kampf gegen die AFD der Parteichef
sagt dazu im ZDF soll man Interview
heute dies
wir müssen uns jetzt wieder stärker auf
den Osten fokussieren tun das auch und
Gregor Gysi und ich haben ja am Anfang
dieser Woche auch ein Plan für ein
gerechtes Land vorgeschlagen wo wir
unter anderem eine Lohn Offensive Ost
fordern dass die Parteiführung bei der
Vorstellung dieses linken Sozialplans
der eigenen Zugkraft in der selbst nicht
ganz traut darauf deutet eben wenn man
einspannte für dieses Zukunftsprojekt
was ich mir vor allem ja auch noch nicht
hätte vorstellen können wieder eine
Rundreise wo Mitglieder Sympathisanten
und Sympathisanten an andere aufgerufen
sind hinzukommen ich bin ja noch sehr
jung ich bin ja erst 75 Jahre alt all
das auch Versuche im Kampf gegen
weiteren Bedeutungsverlust der
ihretwegen droht seit Monaten kokettiert
Sahra Wagenknecht mit der Gründung einer
eigenen Partei während nicht nur sie vor
fehlender inhaltlicher Schärfe und einer
grünisierung der Partei warnt machte
deren Führung zum Unmut vieler ohne
Rücksprache mit der Basis die parteilose
Aktivistin Carola Rakete zur
Spitzenkandidatin für die Europawahl
die Klimakrise ist die größte
gerechtigkeitskrise der Welt und in der
Ukraine muss die Perspektive der
Betroffenen im Zentrum stehen einig ist
man sich sehr weitgehend bei einem der
Ablehnung der AFD allerdings nach großer
Empörung über CDU-Chef März zeigte sich
auch bei der Linken gab es auf
kommunaler Ebene schon mehrfach
gemeinsames stimmen mit der AFD na gut
wenn einzelne sozusagen in einer
Situation so reagieren aber die Partei
dann trotzdem geschlossen zeigt dass das
nicht geht dann ist das auch richtig das
ist doch klar dass die parteiposition
das ist jedoch keineswegs bei allen
bekannt gewordenen Fällen gab es
handfeste Konsequenzen etwa in Form
eingeleitete Parteiausschlussverfahren
das nächste Jahr dürfte nun die Richtung
weisen für die Linke neben der
Europawahl stehen dann im Osten
Deutschlands drei Landtagswahlen und
viele Kommunalwahlen an auch dies
allesamt Herausforderungen der Kategorie
nicht so leicht zu lösen
Wohngemeinschaft zu und nicht so leicht
zu lösen ist auch das nächste Problem es
geht im weiteren Sinne um
Urlaubsregionen und im engeren Sinne um
die Gastronomie die findet ob in der
Hauptstadt auf dem Dorf oder in den
Bergen kaum noch Personal insbesondere
durch die pandemiezeit hat sich das
Problem sogar noch mal verschärft wohl
auch weil manche aus der Not heraus
festgestellt haben dass es andere und
angenehmere Jobs gibt also sind viele
nicht mehr in den alten Job
zurückgekehrt was aber möglicherweise
zurückkehren wird ist die Mehrwertsteuer
von 19 Prozent die ja während der
Pandemie auf 7% gesenkt wurde Claudia
Vogelmann
seit 20 Jahren ist der wird seit einiger
Zeit steht Uli Weissner als Koch in
seiner Restaurant Küche alleine am Herd
er findet wie so viele Kollegen kein
Personal
[Musik]
suchen seit zehn Jahren wird die
Situation immer schwieriger gute
motivierte Leute zu finden und deswegen
haben wir uns jetzt entschlossen ein
anderes Konzept zu fahren und das
alleine zu machen weil wir sonst die
Qualität nicht halten können sein Lokal
die Auszeit ist Teil eines
Kongresszentrums in Murnau sieben
Mitarbeiter hatte er früher nun stehen
nur noch seine Frau und er im Lokal es
gibt nur noch 50 anstatt 100 Plätze die
meistens haben sich mit dem
Personalmangel abgefunden doch nun Thron
höhere Steuern der Mehrwertsteuersatz
auf Speisen der in der corona-krise auf
7% reduziert wurde soll Anfang kommenden
Jahres wieder auf 19% erhöht werden wir
haben normalerweise kalkulatorischen
Durchschnitt von 10 bis 15%, was für den
wird hängen bleibt
wenn wir die Mehrwertsteuer wenn jetzt
erhöht wird dann wird diese Maße
natürlich schon sehr dünn und wir müssen
unseren Personal mehr bezahlen dass wir
hoffentlich bekommen
es lohnt sich dann irgendwann nicht mehr
die Auszeit hat montags und dienstags
geschlossen viele Gaststätten in der
Region Ruhetage kann sich in der
Hotelbranche niemand erlauben der
Betrieb muss laufen auch in der Küche
doch im Alpenhof in Murnau wird sich das
Gute Wiener Schnitzel nicht mehr jeder
Gast leisten wenn der alte
Mehrwertsteuersatz kommt
wenn wir es runterrechnen auf das
Schnitzel dann wird jeder sagen wieso
ist es so teuer aber die teuerste Säure
ist das was außen herum ist die
Gastronomie wo überall jede Woche jeden
Monat die höhere Kosten sind und wir
können aber nicht das ganze auf den Gast
umlegen es zeigt um die man 50 Euro für
Schnitzel oder 40 €. Christian Bär
beschäftigt 150 Mitarbeiter aus 17
Nationen lange hat er nach ihnen gesucht
nun ist jede freie Stelle in seinem Haus
besetzt
160 Gäste machen hier gerade Urlaub doch
er bräuchte 220 damit sich die
Personalkosten rechnen
es gibt Gäste die kommen gar nicht mehr
weil sie sagen sie machen keinen Urlaub
es gibt Gäste die wollen sich nicht
festlegen und Buchen ganz kurzfristig
und dann gibt's Gäste die Buchen einfach
kürzer und die die sich an den Urlaub in
Oberbayern überhaupt noch leisten können
achten mehr denn je aufs Geld auch in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen so der
tourismussche manche Dinge bleiben etwas
weniger oder fallen ganz aus einkaufen
vielleicht weniger hochwertig essen
gehen das sind so reduzierte
Ausgabeverhalten was wir gerade
feststellen können müssen
Hochsaison in den bayerischen Alpen in
diesen Zeiten ist nicht alles eitel
Sonnenschein
und nun zum Sport an diesem Sonntag
zunächst in Kürze Meldungen von
glücklichen Triumphen beim ATP-Turnier
am Hamburger roten Baum hat sich der
deutsche Topspieler Alexander Zverev
einen lang gehegten Traum erfüllt und
gewonnen im Finale bezwang er den Serben
Laszlo Jere in zwei Sätzen es ist der
erste Turniersieg für Zverev nach einer
schweren Knöchelverletzung im
vergangenen Jahr und der erste deutsche
Triumph in Hamburg seit 30 Jahren
[Applaus]
Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen hat
auch den Großen Preis von Belgien
gewonnen vor seinem Red bull-kollegen
Sergio Perez es ist der 8 Triumph des
Niederländers hintereinander damit hat
der 25-Jährige die Bestmarke von Michael
Schumacher übertroffen der 2004 sieben
Rennen in Folge gewann
zum deutschen Spiel bei der Fußball-WM
der Frauen gleich hier zunächst die
anderen Ergebnisse für Neuseeland ist
die Heim WM beendet die
co-gastgeberinnen sind mit dem 0:0 gegen
die Schweiz enttäuscht ausgeschieden die
Schweiz steht im Achtelfinale ebenso wie
die Spielerinnen aus Norwegen mit ihrem
klaren 6 zu 0 Sieg gegen die Philippinen
und der nächste Gruppengegner der
deutschen Spielerinnen Südkorea verlor
gegen Marokko Null zu eins
ja und wir blicken jetzt auf den
heutigen Gruppengegner und der hieß im
zweiten Gruppenspiel Kolumbien dass das
eine deutlich härtere Partie werden
würde nicht nur weil ein Großteil der
Fans im Stadion die Südamerikanerinnen
anfeuerte das war eigentlich allen klar
der Grund die Spielerinnen sind einfach
körperlich deutlich robuster als die
ersten Gegnerinnen aus Marokko zwei
Kampf stark ist da noch untertrieben
Zweikampf hart trifft es eher und so ist
auch das Endergebnis hart aus deutscher
Sicht Michael Pfeiffer
bitte diese Niederlage denn im letzten
Moment schenkt die DFB-Auswahl Kolumbien
einen Sieg ein Blackout in der
Nachspielzeit 97 Minute ich finde du
musst damit um 1:1 einfach auch
herausgehen
einerseits Zeichen dass die Mannschaft
aus dass sie das Gefühl hatten wir
machen aber jetzt noch den Sieg Treffer
andersrum muss man natürlich ein Stück
weit auch erwarten dass man da ein
bisschen cleverer agiert denn Manuela
war wird nicht attackiert kann
ungehindert zum zwei zu eins einköpfen
schon enttäuscht natürlich weil ja
dieses letzte Tor einfach brutal
ärgerlich war denn die Kapitänin trifft
per Elfmeter zum Ausgleich zwar erst in
der 88 minute aber nach vielen starken
Angriffen von denen der beste zum
Strafstoß führt nach herrlicher
beistafette wird Lena Oberdorf beste
deutsche heute gekauft
wir arbeiten uns so gut rein haben so
eine gute Moral mit mit dem Anschluss
dann auch gezeigt wann dran haben immer
mehr Druck ausgeübt schaffen es aber
dann in den in den letzten Metern in den
letzten Momenten einfach nicht ja den
Ball richtig durchzudrücken richtig in
den 16er zu bringen die verletzte
Felicitas Rauch und Team Maskottchen war
wo erleben aber zuvor eine Darbietung
der Extraklasse zum 1:0 für Kolumbien
wie erst 18-jährige Linda kaissedo
inzwischen bei Real Madrid degradiert
Hut und debrets zu Statistinnen
Kolumbien tanzt ins Achtelfinale die
Deutschen müssen gegen Südkorea im
letzten Gruppenspiel nachsitzen
und der Kollege heißt nicht Pfeiffer
sondern Pfeffer und den können das die
deutsche Nationalmannschaft sicherlich
am Donnerstag auch ganz gut gebrauchen
also beim dritten und letzten
Vorrundenspiel um 12 Uhr und das können
sie dann bei uns sehen was in der Woche
noch ansteht jetzt im Ausblick von
Franziska
[Musik]
am Dienstag wird in Lissabon der
internationale Weltjugendtag der
katholischen Kirche beginnen junge
Gläubiger aus aller Welt werden in die
portugiesische Hauptstadt kommen für
gemeinsame Andachten Konzerte und Gebete
auch Papst franziskus wird mit dabei
sein
am Dienstag vor 25 Jahren trat die neue
deutsche Rechtschreibung in Kraft die
vor allem für Schüler einfacher werden
sollte Kritik an den neuen Regeln kam
von Schriftstellern Lehrern und
Wissenschaftlern am Ende ging der Streit
bis vors Verfassungsgericht das die
Reform belegte
am Mittwoch wird der sogenannte
erdüberlastungstag erreicht sein an
diesem Tag werden alle ökologischen
Ressourcen verbraucht sein die die Erde
in diesem Jahr noch regenerieren kann
Hitzewellen Dürren und Überschwemmungen
laut Wissenschaftlern auch Konsequenzen
der Überlastung
ob Mittwoch wird ein kleines Dorf in
Schleswig-Holstein wieder zur
Pilgerstätte des Heavy Metal mit dem
Wacken Open Air startet eines der
weltweit größten Festivals der Szene
vier Tage lang feiern die rund 85.000
Besucher mit internationalen Superstars
wie Iron Maiden
[Applaus]
und das Wetter in dieser neuen Woche in
der in ganz Deutschland Sommerferien
sind wird unbeständig nass und frisch
morgen gibt es im Norden teils kräftigen
und lang anhaltenden Regen vereinzelt
auch Gewitter im Süden weitgehend
trocken und größere sonnige Abschnitte
bei lebhaftem Südwestwind 18 bis 26 Grad
die weiteren Aussichten sehr unbeständig
und windig bei ähnlichen Temperaturen
und das war es für und von uns beiden
für heute morgen erwarten Sie dann hier
Christian Sievers und Hanna Zimmermann
zum heute-journal und wir weisen Sie
sehr gerne noch auf ein fliehendes Pferd
hin heute Nacht ab 0.30 Uhr hier im
Programm und dann auch in der ZDF
Mediathek also eine Martin weiser
Verfilmung in Erinnerung an den gerade
verstorbenen und sehr besonderen
Schriftsteller und Intellektuellen
machen sie es gut wo auch immer Sie sind
[Musik]